20 pieds de haut et capté à capter plus
de gs qu'un arbre de tremper le
romancier le principe scientifique on
nous explique que le carbone est saisi
par la helaba grandir grâce à cette
captation du carbone
le ministre des forêts en a surpris
plusieurs lundi en affirmant qu'il était
possible de diminuer les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en coupant plus
d'arbres avec nous et plenty faux
professeur agrégé au département des
sciences du bois et de la forêt de
l'université laval madame tifo bonsoir
est-ce qu'il est exact de dire qu'on
réduit les gaz à effet de serre en
coupant plus d'arbres en fait il faut
qu'on regarde l'histoire complète le
sang parle juste de couper des arbres on
manque une partie importante de
l'histoire en fait on ne coupe pas des
arbres pour le plaisir de couper des
arbres
ça fait partie d'un système
d'aménagement forestier donc la récolte
et à quoi faire c'est d'envoyer des bois
sur les marchés donc pour servir de
matériau ou d'énergie et donc encore
regarde l'histoire complète donc la
récolte qui permettent de mobiliser des
matériaux d'énergies renouvelables pour
répondre aux besoins de la société
là on peut être dans une dynamique de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre parce
qu'on parle d'atténuation on parle
d'adaptation expliquez nous un peu
comment ça fonctionne
en fait quand on parle d'atténuation et
d'adaptation c'est un peu comme un les
joueurs offensifs et les joueurs
défensifs d'une équipe de football donc
par rapport au changement climatique on
veut lutter contre les changements
climatiques donc réduire les émissions
donc réduire le changement climatique si
c'est la partie atténuation la partie
adaptation on est plutôt en mode
défensif malgré nos efforts le climat va
continuer à changer donc on veut adapter
nos territoires adapter nos sociétés à
nos écosystèmes à ce climat qui va être
changé donc si c'est la partie défense
est donc un rebond plan de lutte aux
changements climatiques va avoir les
joueurs à la fois en france et fait des
français donc d'atténuation et
d'adaptation et donc de couper des
arbres c'est dans la partie offensive
sur wii ça peut faire partir la partie
en france et il va en fait elle est le
ministre des forêts
y'a pas de sursaut ne le parlent ceux ci
reconnu par par le giec dans le fameux
giec le groupe intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat qui dans ses
rapports reconnaît le rôle essentiel des
forêts et des produits du bois dans la
lutte aux changements climatiques donc
dans la partie d'atténuation ce que le
logis ac 10 et qu'un aménagement
forestier durable qui fournit un flux
continu de matériaux et d'énergie
renouvelables vont faire partie d'une
stratégie de lutte aux changements
climatiques
ok mais il y en a qui disent on installe
il faut tenir compte de plusieurs autres
enjeux notamment la protection des
espèces par exemple où certains je
lisais 50% des produits issus des coupes
forestières ont une durée de vie qui
peut être courte ou 70% du carbone est
perdue entre la récolte et le produit
final
donc il ya des gens qui mettent en doute
cette affirmation comme quoi la coupe
forestière contribuer à la réduction des
gaz à effet de serre mais en fait elle
peut contribuer dans la mesure où ce
qu'on est très très bon très très
efficace avec le bois qui est récolté
donc il faut s'assurer qu'avait que
chaque mètre cube de bois qu'on récolte
on fait le maximum en termes de produits
de longue durée donc des matériaux qui
vont me faire servir dans la
construction et durer toute une vie ou
faire dd des sources d'énergie de
bioénergie et qui vont me remplacer des
carburants fossiles très polluant donc
si on est très efficace dans notre
transformation donc on s'assure d'aller
de produire un maximum de matériaux
d'énergie par rapport à des résidus et
que ces matériaux ces énergies là on les
utilise le mieux possible sur les
marchés pour remplacer par exemple les
produits qui ont une très forte
empreinte carbone ou des sources
d'énergie à très forte empreinte carbone
là on va être efficace donc c'est
vraiment ce système complet mais ça
prend de la machinerie ça prend du
transport faut quand même sortir le bois
du de la forêt et ça c'est émetteur de
gaz à effet de serre quand même oui mais
quand on regarde le bilan carbone
complet et je pense ma vie refaire ça
est la partie récolte du bois transports
c'est quand même assez faible comme un
commission là quand on regarde le bilan
complet le cycle du carbone
auray et après ça leur rôle des produits
du bois sur les marchés la partie de
l'école transport transformation se sait
pas c'est pas quelque chose qui est
significatif c'est vraiment la partie
significative c'est l'efficacité de
transformation puis après c'est ce qu'on
fait sur les marchés avec notre bois
c'est bien parce que vous passez votre
vie à faire ce qu on vous sait vite
parce que vous avez l'expertisé pour
nous en parler
faites-nous donc un peu le portrait de
la récolte la coupe la transformation de
bois au québec on a un tableau
d'ailleurs là-dessus enfin en termes de
volumes récoltés là on voit dans la
forêt publique ces 22 millions de mètres
cube c'est ça ouais donc ça représente
le banc les volumes les volumes récoltés
annuellement donc surtout en forêt
publique la 90% à peu près de notre
forêt québécoise est un souteneur public
donc c'est un chiffre important et
intéressant
un autre chiffre important à savoir
toutefois c'est que ce niveau de récolte
là mais il ya le niveau possible de
récoltes au québec ce qu'on appelle la
possibilité forestière annuelle de cours
ça c'est calculé par un bureau qu'on
appelle le forestier en chef donc étant
un bureau indépendant et qui calcule la
scala à la forêt québécoise est capable
de produire
année après année de manière durable
donc le niveau de récolte maximale que
quand on peut aller chercher et c'est ce
qu'on dit la possibilité soit récemment
forêts publiques au québec est à peu
près de 30 2 millions mètres cubes donc
la coupe près annuelle est de 22
millions la possibilité de 32 millions
oui donc il ya un espace de croissance
qui est là donc d'après ces chiffres là
il serait possible d'augmenter notre
niveau de récolte en restant dans les
limites d'une récolte durable et de
s'assurer de la régénération de nos
forêts ouais ça c'est la partie
important donc la la la coupe du bois la
mobilisation des produits du bois ne
fait du sens que si ça s'inscrit dans un
contexte aménagement forestier durable
dont il faut s'assurer que la forêt à sa
repousse aussi bien après qu'on soit
passé que qu'avant donc ça c'est une
partie une partie fondamentale mais
c'est au coeur de notre de notre régime
forestier au québec
est ce que c'est une bonne idée de
planter deux milliards d'arbres comme le
propose justin trudeau
c'est sûr qu'à planter des arbres on
peut pas être contre conques idée de
planter des armes c'est un beau c'est un
beau symbole
et on va pas sauver le monde avec ça
c'est sûr au canada on plante déjà à peu
près 600 millions d'arbres par année à
peu près 120 5 millions au québec dont
caen planté 2 milliards de plus ben
pourquoi pas avoir un certain bénéfice
d'un point de vue séquestration de
carbone
pas suffisamment pour sauver
sauver la planète en sentant il ya
toutes sortes dans au très bon retombées
positives à la plantation d'arbres c'est
sous la zone euro parce qu'il faut
s'arrêter d'un petit fou là dessus merci
beaucoup merci à vous pour voir